>>> THIS MORNING, CBS NEWS
BEGINS "EYE ON EARTH: OUR PLANET
IN PERIL," SPECIAL SKOCOVERAGE
OUR CHANGING PLANET LEADING UP
TO EARTH DAY.
THIS THURSDAY IN A POLL, 56% OF
AMERICANS SAY CLIMATE CHANGE IS
URGENT AND SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
RIGHT NOW.
RISING SEA LEVELS ARE AMONG THE
MOST VISIBLE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WITH WATER COVERING MORE
THAN 70% OF THE EARTH'S SURFACE.
IT'S KEY TO OUR SURVIVAL.
MARK PHILIPS VOLUNTEERED TO GO
OUT IN THAT SNAZZY OUTFIT TO
REPORT ON HOW THIS FORCE OF
NATURE AFFECTS US ALL.
>> Reporter: THIS MAY BE THE
MOST SELF-INDULGENT BUT IT'S FOR
A GOOD CAUSE.
THEY WANTED TO FOCUS ON THE
CLIMATE CHANGE CRISIS IN A WAY
THAT PEOPLE CAN RELATE TO.
THEY SAID LET'S LOOK AT SPECIFIC
WAYS IN WHICH LIVES ARE BEING
AFFECTED.
LET'S LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING,
FOR EXAMPLE, WITH WATER.
SO I SAID, WATER?
I KNOW WHERE TO FIND SOME.
ONCE THIS WAS A WORLD OF WIND
AND WATER AND SUN.
NOW WE CALL THEM RENEWABLES.
OFFSHORE WIND FARMS, SOLAR POWER
ARRAYS, BUT THIS IS ACTUALLY A
GOOD PLACE TO START A SERIES ON
CLIMATE CHANGE BECAUSE THE
EFFECTS ARE OFTEN FELT OUT HERE
FIRST, AND WHAT HAPPENS HERE
AFFECTS EVERYWHERE ELSE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT GLOBAL WARMING
IS RAISING SEA TEMPERAURES AND
THAWING THE ICE CAPS IN THE
NORTH AND SOUTH POLAR REGIONS,
AND WE KNOW THAT AS CHUNKS OF
GLACIER EARS AND ICE SHEETS
BREAK OFF AND FLOAT AWAY THEY
MELT CAUSING SEA LEVELS AROUND
THE WORLD TO RISE.
HOW MUCH IS THE SEA LEVEL
RISING?
WE KNOW THAT, TOO.
ACCORDING TO NASA, SEA LEVELS
ARE UP SINCE THE YEAR 1900 ABOUT
EIGHT INCHES.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE RATE
THE WATERS ARE RISING IS
SPEEDING UP.
REMEMBER WHEN HURRICANE SANDY
HIT NEW YORK CITY IN 2012?
GET USED TO IT.
SEVERE STORM FLOODING USED TO BE
CONSIDERED A ONCE EVERY 500-YEAR
EVENT.
NOW IT'S ONCE EVERY 25 YEARS.
AND WITHIN THE NEXT THREE
DECADES, THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF
SCIENCE PREDICTS IT MAY HAPPEN
ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PEER INTO THE
FUTURE TO GET A SENSE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT ARE HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND
RIGHT HERE.
YOU SEE THAT OLD FORTIFICATION
OVER THERE?
IT WAS BUILT 500 YEARS AGO BY
HENRY VIII TO KEEP THE FRENCH
OUT OF THESE WATERS.
500 YEARS AGO, HE BUILT IT TO
LAST.
UNLIKE HIS MARRIAGES MAYBE.
BUT LAST WINTER, A STORM ROSE
UP, AND THE WATERS ROSE UP, AND
IT COLLAPSED, 500 YEARS.
WEATHER PATTERNS AREN'T WHAT
THEY USED TO BE.
>> WE GET THE HIGHEST TIDES, THE
STRONGEST STORMS, THE WARMEST
WI
WINTERS, THE WETTEST SUMMERS,
ALL THESE EXTREMES ARE HAPPENING
YEAR AFTER YEAR.
>> Reporter: TEMPERATURES, SEA
LEVELS, AND STORMS YOU CAN
MEASURE.
BUT THE OCEANS PLAY ANOTHER MORE
MYSTERIOUS ROLE IN THE CLIMATE
STORY.
IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE OCEANS,
THE PLANET WOULD BE WARMING EVEN
FASTER.
>> ONE OF THE NEW AREAS OF STUDY
IS WHAT WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF ROLE THE WORLD'S
OCEANS HAVE PLAYED REALLY IN
PROTECTING US FROM OURSELVES.
>> THE OCEANS ARE A HUGE HEAT
STORE.
THEY ABSORB THAT ENERGY FROM THE
SUN EFFICIENTLY.
>> Reporter: LIKE A STORAGE
HEATER.
>> A HUGE STORAGE HEATER.
THE EARTH IS 71%, 72% OCEAN.
IT HAS A -- IT'S BUFFERING THAT
ENERGY.
>> Reporter: I FEEL A "BUT"
COMING.
>> THE BIG BUT IS WITH ANY
STORAGE HEATER, THAT ENERGY'S
THERE, AND IT COULD COME BACK
AND BITE US.
>> Reporter: A LOT OF SCIENTISTS
THINK THOSE WEATHER EXTREMES AND
THOSE RISING WATERS ARE EVIDENCE
THE BITE-BACK HAS ALREADY BEGUN.
WHEN YOU SAIL THROUGH THESE
WATERS, YOU SAIL THROUGH THE
WAKE OF HISTORY.
NATURAL AND HUMAN.
BUT NOW FOR THE FIRST TIME, ONE
OF THE ANIMAL SPECIES ON THIS
PLANET IS DETERMINING THE COURSE
OF THE WHOLE WORLD'S FUTURE.
THAT SPECIES, OF COURSE, IS US.
FOR "CBS THIS MORNING," I'M MARK
PHILIPS, SOMEWHERE IN THE
ENGLISH CHANNEL.
>> NICELY DON